okay so how has your relationship with  driving change before and after this  film you have the need for speed now I'm  definitely you know I'm just saying I've  been banned from motorcycles by my  family and so I do go I still miss I  miss that being out on the track and so  you know I was learning from the best on  this and so yeah I'll be keeping in  touch with him about I mean I wanted to  be a driver ever since I was a little  girl so I'm going it's going great I'm  here on your own E to you I'll do a  ride-along someday that's my dream now  here it's right now here at if there are  there are two Batmen here we have Robert  Pattinson here and you're here as well  although all the best to him you know I  think is absolutely fantastic actor  wonderful choice for Batman  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]